dup leader sir jeffrey donaldson is
speaking today
met earlier this morning with the
secretary of state
we've had internal party meetings
our group has met for the first time
since the campaign delighted that all of
our members are here today to register
for the assembly
and we want to see this place up and
running as soon as possible we want
stable
devolved government we are committed
to
our participation in those institutions
however as i have made clear before the
election
during the collect the election campaign
at every opportunity and
now
post-election our position remains as it
was and that is that we need to see the
issues around the protocol
dealt with decisively by the government
we need decisive action by the
government to address the difficulties
created by the protocol whether that is
driving up the cost of living whether
that is the harm that it's doing to
businesses on our economy
or indeed
in undermining political stability in
northern ireland the protocol needs to
be dealt with
we sought a mandate from people
to
adopt the stance that we have taken
and we will continue as we recognize
others
also have a democratic mandate we want
to work with them to deliver
stable government for northern ireland
but the long shadow of the protocol
is casting
its mark over this place
it needs to be dealt with i want stable
government i want government to have
sound foundations the protocol
undermines the foundations of our
political institutions
it has altered our constitutional status
without our consent it has created a
border in the rsc without our consent it
needs to be dealt with this along with
our other priorities is what
my team is dedicated to addressing we
stand by the commitments we made in our
manifesto our five-point plan and key to
that is getting the stability that we
need to move forward to address the
issues that matter to everyone in
northern ireland i'm going to take
a a number a short number of questions
and then i have a bilateral meeting that
i've got to participate in with some of
the other parties so you'll forgive me
if i've got to move on so
[Music]
well it is democracy because we saw the
mandate sinn fein at every general
election seek a mandate not to take
their seats at westminster and they
don't take their seats at westminster
and no one blames them
people the other political parties don't
point the finger at them because they
say we have a mandate well i have a
mandate the dup has a mandate and our
mandate is clear
we want to see political stability we
are we are democrats we want the
political institutions to work but we
re-entered the
institutions on the basis of new decade
new approach that remains the agreement
that formed the basis of power sharing
in northern ireland after three long
years of shin-fi and boycotting these
institutions
new decade new approach the government
gave a firm commitment to protect
northern ireland's place within the uk
internal market two and a half years
later they've done nothing to honor that
commitment i'm holding them to that
commitment tomorrow i will be holding
the prime minister to that commitment
and that's what i will continue to do
until this job is done until the
government honors what it said it would
do protect northern ireland's place
within the united kingdom that's what
needs to happen that's what i sought a
mandate from the people of northern
ireland to do and i'm asking other
democratic parties to respect my mandate
as much as they want me to respect
theirs what i will not do vicky
i'm not going to go back in my word
i'm not going to say one thing to the
electorate on the day after the election
do a vote fast i'm not going to do that
i give my word i saw the mandate on the
basis of sorting out the protocol i'm
committed to doing that the sooner it
happens the better
[Music]
well um the other unionist parties must
speak for themselves uh i am clear we
will nominate to the executive as soon
as the government takes decisive action
to deal with the protocol the man with
the stopwatch is brandon lewis the
people who can deliver the change
are boris johnson on the government we
are very clear but that frankly the
sooner they do it the sooner we get
things properly functioning again here
storm that is what is i want that is
what i am committed to but i don't
control the timing of that the the ball
is now firmly at the foot of the
government they have talked for a long
time
last july they published a command paper
they set out very clearly what the
problem was they accepted there was a
major problem with the protocol but they
have yet to take the steps that are
necessary to address that problem so i
want the government to act i expect the
government to act they know what they
need to do i made that clear to the
secretary of state this morning
well um you know they've been at this
for months
and months and months
and last september i set out very
clearly the steps that my party would
take in the absence of agreement between
the eu and the uk government i was
patient i gave more time
i extended
what i thought were realistic and
unreasonable
time frames i extended them but this has
been dragged on and dragged on
and i'm not prepared to watch and stand
on the sidelines as the can has kicked
further down the road that's not
acceptable they've had months to sort
this out it is their responsibility to
do so and i'm saying to the eu and to
the uk government i'm not interested in
their parallel universe i'm interested
in the real world which means sort this
out and take the action now to remove
the rec border
thank you very much